THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING WE HAVE
THIRTY ONE BILLS CONSIDER THIS
MORNING BEFORE WE BEGIN WE HAVE
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES. I'D
LIKE TO THINK FIRST OF ALL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
MCCARTY- FOR COVERING VACANCIES
AND I'D LIKE TO REMIND EVERYONE
PRESENT HERE THAT YOU'RE
REQUIRED TO STILL WEAR A MASK
WE DO HAVE ROLES IN THE-
PERFORATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. AND WE ILL ABIDE BY
THOSE RULES RELIGIOUSLY. SO IF
YOU ARE IN THE BUILDING- YOU
CAN'T OF COURSE SPEAK ON A BILL.
IF YOU WERE NOT ALREADY PRE
APPROVED AS A WITNESS- YOU WERE
NOT SPEAKING EXCEPT TO SAY YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. IF YOU ARE A WITNESS YOU
CAN SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES AT
ABOUT ONLY THE FINANCIAL
CONSIDERATIONS OF THE BILL WE
THE POLICY IS TAKING CARE OF IN
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES THIS IS
ABOUT- BUT COSTS. AND WITH THAT
BUT I THINK THERE ARE PEOPLE
CALLING IN AS WELL WE WILL GO
THROUGH IT IF A BILL IS NOT
PRESENTED ON AND IT HAS BEEN
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE- YOU
WILL HAVE A CHANCE AT THE END
OF THE MEETING TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THAT
BILL. I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
THE SENATORS THAT. THEY NEED TO
COME IF THEY WANT TO PRESENT ON
THEIR BILLS IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE. MR CORTEZ C. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE NOW. BUT WE HAVE A
QUORUM LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE
ROLE BUT I WILL SAY TO THE
SENATORS- IF THERE'S NO SENATOR
HERE IN THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES
WE WILL SHUT DOWN THE COMMITTEE
AND YOUR BILL WILL BE MOVED TO
NEXT WEEK. SO REMOTE CENTER ON
THE NORTH. WE HAVE A REMOTE
TESTIMONY CENTER ON THE NORTH
STEPS WELL WE'LL SEE IF
ANYBODY'S THERE AS WELL BUT
LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLL. GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW
RIGHT BRIAN. CALDERON CARILLO
TELL DOLLY. AB FONG GABRIEL
EDUARDO GARCIA LIVING QUIRK.
HOLDEN ROBERT RIVAS WEBER.
MCCARTY FOR VACANCY. THANK YOU-
I'VE STILL SEEN NO SENATORS
PRESENT MR CORTEZ HE- SENATOR
DID ALSO MISTER MAN MR WHITE
HOUSE SKI ALL HAVE BILLS THAT
NEED TO BE PRESENTED ON IN THE
MEANTIME WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
LIST OUT THE BILLS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT. THE CONTENT. WITH A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW AND
AS- BY MR FONG. SB FIVE ANYONE
ATKINS SB TWO FOURTEEN BATES SB
SIX FORTY BAKER S. B. TWENTY
FOUR COUNTY AREA SB THREE FOUR
SEVEN CABALLERO SB FIVE SIX
FOUR CORTES C. SB SEVEN OH NINE
DOLLY SB FOUR SEVEN NINE
LAYERED SB FIVE FOUR FOUR
LAYERED. SB THREE OH EIGHT MEN
SB THREE FIFTEEN ROTH SB THREE
FIVE THREE ROTH SB SEVEN A ONE
COMEDIAN EDUCATION SB EIGHT TWO
TWO COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. THAT IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO GETS
OUT ON A ROLL ALL. AT THIS
TIME WE WILL LIST THE BILLS
THAT ARE BEING MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. ACA THREE
KAMLAGER SB FOUR THREE THREE
ALLEN SB SIX TO EIGHT ALLEN S.
B. TWO OH EIGHT DAHLE A. S. B.
FOUR NINE FOUR DODD SB FOUR SIX
FIVE EGGMAN. SB FOUR FIVE TWO
GONZALEZ S. B. EIGHTY FOR HER
TITLE SB FOUR FOUR WONDER TADO
SB FIVE THREE FOUR JONES SB
FIVE SEVEN EIGHT JONES SB THREE
SIX NINE PAN S. B. SEVEN THREE
WIENER. THAT IS THE SUSPENSE
FILE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT- FOR
BILLS. IT IS NINE OH SEVEN THIS
COMMITTEE STARTS AT NINE
O'CLOCK WE WILL- STAY UNTIL.
NINE TEN. SO IF YOU ARE A
SENATOR A STAFF OF A SENATOR.
THAT HAS ONE OF THESE BILLS.
MAY WANT TO GET DOWN HERE. WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS GO GOOD IDEA
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AND TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
BILLS THAT WERE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WHERE AUTHORS
HAVE A WAVE PRESENTATION AT
THIS POINT- OPERATOR WILL GET
THE SUSPENSE LINE FOR BILLS- ON
SUSPENSE WERE AUTHORS. WAVES
PRESENTATION. YOU FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. ON ANY OF
THEM ON THE SUSPEND FILE. AND
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU WE GOT ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE'LL TAKE THAT ONE IN THE
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO THE
CHAMBERS. OKAY THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN I COMMENTED AS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. FOR ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO- OKAY WE DO
HAVE THAT ONE- IT IS ONLINE TEN
OKAY. YOUR LINE IS A- I THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING JEFF MEMBERS
LIKE THAT WHEN YOU'RE OUT YOU
GET YEAH IF YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY WANT TO COUPLE TO COME
IN FOR STRONG SUPPORTER EIGHTY
THREE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND NOW
WE HAVE A AUTHOR HEARING THANK
YOU MISTER WHITE HOUSE SKI SB
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A-
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY
PROCEED. MENTORS ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THIS IS LESS THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TODAY
IT'S EASIER CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO WITNESSES
LISTED WILL HAD A GO AHEAD AND
ALLOW THE PHONES ON SB FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. IRWIN AND NEVER
REALLY RECOVERED A FINANCE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU ARE THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING CHECK ON
BALLOT VICE CHAIR BIGELOW AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS MILLION YEN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WE HAVE ACTUALLY NO FILE IN
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MANAGER THANK YOU WILL GO AHEAD
AND I SEE NOBODY GETTING UP IN
THE- GALLERY. I SEE NOBODY ON
THE OUTSIDE REMOTE STATION.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO PUT THAT ON
HOLD UNTIL WE GET IT YOU KNOW
ALL RIGHT WE ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE TO PUT THAT ON CALL THANK
YOU MISTER WHAT KOWSKI THAT
GETS OUT ON E. WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING WITH
MISSED ALL THE VOTING HOMES TO
BE GLOBALLY NOW. THANK YOU
THANK YOU R CORTEZ HE DICEY OF
COMMAND MR CORTEZ HE HAS SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A
SECONDS. BY MR HOLDEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS AMERICAN.
P. THREE EIGHTY THREE THE
JUVENILE DIVERSION ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WHICH SEEKS
TO EXPAND THE REHABILITATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUTH COMMIT
NONVIOLENT FELONIES BANK RECENT
ACCESS TO DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
BY DOING THIS WE CAN ASSURE THE
SPECIALIZED SOLUTIONS PROVIDER
FOR YOU THE STATE OF A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH. MONODY
RESEARCH ON ADOLESCENT BEHAVIOR
BRING DEVELOPMENT OF COURSE
CONFIRMS THAT YOUTHFULNESS
MATTERS IN THE YOU SHOULD BE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY THAN
ADULTS. SB THREE EIGHTY THREE
SOMETHING FALLS THIS RESEARCH
BY MAKING YOU'VE CHARGED WITH
FELONIES ARE NOT SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT. ELIGIBLE FOR INFORMAL
SUPERVISION ADDITIONALLY SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE. INSURES
THAT YOUTH ALLEGED TO HAVE SOLD
PRESERVES. SILVA TOLD SUBSTANCE
ARE NOT EXCLUDED FROM RECEIVING
INFORMAL SUPERVISION. BY
CREATING PATHWAYS TO DIVERSION
SB THREE EIGHTY THREE WILL
CONTINUE TO REDUCE THE PRICE
TAG OF INCARCERATION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
DO WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GIVE A FILE ON THIS AND
THE PHONES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FILE ON SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU.
AND THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
LISTED SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
ASK ON THE PHONES IS THERE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST STATING YOUR
POSITION TO SB THREE EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU YOUR IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF
THEM ZERO FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CLIFF COSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA- JUDGES ASSOCIATION
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IN MEXICO TO
LINE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING THEN CHEN MEMBERS MANY
THAT WOULD ADDRESS YOU GETS
VDCS CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M I'M
SURE THERE IS NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU I'M- SEE FOLKS IN THE
GALLERY BUT NOBODY IS GETTING
UP TO SPEAK SO- WILL GO TO THE
REMOTE HEARING WHICH- I SUPPOSE
NOBODY'S THERE. I'M NOBODY IN
THE CHAMBER HOUSING QUESTIONS
WITH THAT IT GETS OUT OF B.
ROLL CALL WITH MISTER ALI NOT
VOTING THANK YOU MISTER CORTES
A- FIGMENT OF YOUR MEMBERS.
MISTER MAN. MISTER MAN HAS S.
B. THREE SEVENTY FOUR IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I SEE
A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU CARE CAN
THOSE- MEMBERS COMMITTEE STAFF
I PRESENT TO YOU SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR WHICH AMENDS THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ACT INCLUDE REPRODUCTIVE
COERCION ABUSE THAT CONSISTS OF
CONTROL OVER THE REPRODUCTIVE
AUTONOMY OF ANOTHER THROUGH
THREAT OF FORCE OR INTIMIDATION
THIS IS A VERY COMMON FORM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS NOT
RECOGNIZING A LOT TODAY. SB
THREE SEVENTY FOUR ONE SURE
THAT SURVIVORS OF REPRODUCTIVE
COERCION CAN SEEK A LEGAL
PROTECTIONSTHEY NEED AND
DESERVE THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE AND AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES IT
COMES WITH A MINOR IN A VISIBLE
COSTS TO TRIAL COURTS ONLINE WE
HAVE PROFESSOR JAMES STOVER
FROM UC IRVINE SCHOOL LAWS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CLINIC TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL
GET THE WITNESS ON THE LINE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERS. MY NAME'S
JAMES GALLAGHER. A SURVIVORS
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS. THE
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE SCHOOL OF
LAW. WHERE DIRECTOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CLINIC. IN
INTERDISCIPLINARY. INITIATIVE
AND PLAN WITH IRAQ. HOW OF THE
AND CURRENT CRITICS A PRACTICAL.
IN PRINCIPLE OF THREE SEVENTY
FOUR THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
IS EXTREMELY PERVASIVE AND
HARMFUL FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WOULD HAVE INCREASED
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
ARE KIND OF PREGNANCY. AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SIMPLIFIED
ALITY FOLLOWING THIS VIOLATION
OF ONE'S BODY. THE REQUESTED
QUESTION HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT
PROJECTIONS TO THE DELIGHT AND
VANITY IN PART BECAUSE I WANTED
TO REFLECT WHAT YOU WANT
WITHOUT QUESTION A MEDICAL
OFFICIAL SCIENCE RESEARCH. FROM
HARVARD MANY CLING TO HAVE
EXPERIENCED REQUESTED. THIS
ADDITION TO CALIFORNIA DEMOCRAT
SECTION SIXTY THREE TWENTY IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
BEST IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL GO. TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GIVE A
FILE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
UMPIRE HAS OF POSITION ON THIS
BILL WE DON'T THAT THAT YOU DID
COUNTY REPORT REPORT THAT AND
FISCAL. CREATED BY THIS ARE
MINOR ABSORB. AND DOES NOT
CREATE A STATE ROOM MANDATE.
THANK YOU NOW WILL GO TO
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO
IT SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR ON THE
PHONES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
SEVEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WILLIAM BROUGH
BURKE ON BEHALF OF NAY ROUTE
PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MANAGER THANK YOU I SEE NOBODY
RISING IN THE GALLERY TO SPEAK
AND SEE NOBODY ON THE REMOTE
STATION AND NO QUESTIONS HERE
MISTER MAN THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING WITH
MISS DAHLE AT MISSED ALL THE
VOTING. HI THANK YOU. DALY
DOLLY DALY. WELL AS THE- MISS
DAVIES I'M SORRY ACT I DON'T
HAVE MY GLASSES ON- I USE WERE
TELLING ME I WAS PRONOUNCING IT
WRONG MISS DAVIES VOTING AYE
SORRY. I SHOULD WEAR MY
GLASSES. ALL RIGHT SENATOR DID
ALSO. SAVING THE BEST FOR LAST
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN IT ENJOYS A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY JUST CALLED AROUND YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB TWO
NINETY SEVEN WILL CREATE A
CIVIL PENALTY OF UP TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
AN OPERATOR OR EXCAVATOR WHO
AFTER FAILING TO FOLLOW BIGELOW
REQUIREMENTS DAMAGES THE
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATION CAUSES
THE RELEASE AND CAUSES THE
RELEASE OF HAZARDOUS GAS OR
LIQUID. CURRENTLY IF YOU'RE
GOING TO ESCALATE AROUND A
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATION YOU'RE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO CALL. THE
EIGHT ONE ONE NOTIFICATION
CENTER TO INSURE YOU DON'T
DAMAGE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT PROVIDES ENERGY WATER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND SO ON.
THIS BILL IS ON IN HONOR OF A
WORKER WHO TRAGICALLY LOST HIS
LIFE WHEN A SOLAR COMPANY
FAILED TO CALL EIGHT ONE ONE.
AND DAMAGE TO GAS LINE.
SOCALGAS EMPLOY WAY KILL
PATRICK AND HIS CREW WERE
CALLED. TO FIX A PROBLEM AND
DURING THE WORK POLICING GAS
LEAKING GAS WAS IGNITED. AND OF
MYSTICAL PATRICK WAS KILLED IN
THE EXPLOSION THIS STRATEGY STE
TRAGEDY COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED. HAD THE SOLAR COMPANY
FOLLOW THE LAW. I BELIEVE MORE
SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES WILL
PUNISH THE BAD ACTORS AND
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVE FOR OTHERS TO SIMPLY
CALL EIGHT ONE ONE. THE COST OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS LEGISLATION
WILL LIKELY BE MINOR AND
OBSERVABLE OBSERVABLE AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE. I SEE NO
WITNESSES LISTED WE WILL GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM HAIR FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE AN APPROVED
PETITION FOR THIS BILL WE NOTE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC
GEOLOGIC ENERGY MANAGEMENT
DIVISION THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
INDICATE THIS BILL WILL HAVE NO
FISCAL IMPACT. ON THEIR
OPERATIONS. FURTHER MONEY
COLLECTED AS A RESULT OF
PENALTIES IMPOSED ON OPERATORS
AND EXCAVATORS IS DEPOSITED AT
REVENUE INTO THE- FACE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EXCAVATION
FUND. CAL FIRE DOES NOT HAVE A
REVENUE INCREASE AT THE MID FOR
THE EAR TERM BUT EXPECT THE
INCREASE IN CIVIL PENALTIES.
YOU HAVE MINIMAL TO NO EFFECT.
ON THE REVENUE INTO THE FUNDS-
FINALLY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE PROVIDED
THE FISCAL ESTIMATE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS DEATH-
FINANCES CONTINUING TO EVALUATE
THE DEPARTMENT COST AND
WORKLOAD ESTIMATES. AND ANY
FUTURE REQUESTS FOR RESOURCES
WILL BE ANALYZED DURING THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND GO TO- ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WANTS REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO- SB. TWO NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NINE ONE
NINE ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO PUBLIC COMING TO YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU I SEE NOBODY IN
THE CHAMBER RISING TO SPEAK ON
THIS I SEENOBODY AT THE REMOTE
STATION I SEE NO QUESTIONS
FROM. THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- MR GRASSO THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR FONG
NOT BUDDY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MANAGER WITH THAT SINCE WE TOOK
PUBLIC COMMENT EARLIER- THAT
CONCLUDES OUR APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING.